all right before we get started this is
the part where i think the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by blinkist and if you don't know
blinkist is an app where they've taken
over 3 000 non-fiction titles and
condensed them into 15 minutes you can
read those summaries or you can listen
to them like you would a youtube video
podcast
15 minute ted talk just in a world of so
much knowledge out there to ingest and
not enough time to even scratch the
surface i feel like blinkist came up
with a solution i do appreciate that for
example i was so pleased to see that
they had
cosmos by carl sagan a lot of great
knowledge in cosmos but i feel like
there are a lot of people out there who
don't have that knowledge because they
were like i don't have the time and now
less than 15 minutes can give you some
life-changing perspective from cosmos i
appreciate that and the first 100 people
to click the link below will get
unlimited access for one week to try it
out and if you like it you'll get 25
off the full membership the trials for
seven days you can cancel any time so no
pressure and thank you once again to
blinkist for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now
this movie was surprising
nobody so nobody is the latest in these
john wick-esque movies about normal guy
who might be
secret badass and i'm actually going to
make more than a few john wick
comparisons in this video i don't mean
to make this a john wick comparison
video but i'm going to compare in the
sense of how they did things differently
not oh this one did it better than the
other it's not like that but i feel it's
important to talk about how the two
movies do things differently because
on the surface level if you give someone
the surface level description it sounds
very john wick here's the surface level
description
to nobody seemingly normal guy has a
random encounter with some seemingly
randomly normal douche bags those
randomly normal douche bags are tied to
some very high-powered russians
so now the high-powered russians are
going to come after normal guy and
they're going to find out that normal
guy
might have been a super secret badass in
a previous life and they're going to
regret it
right sounds very wick kind of like
mortal kombat and street fighter
both fighting games but they're not the
same experience well first of all bob
odenkirk is great in this movie because
bob odenkirk's a great actor we always
knew that like you know
he got big after breaking bad but in
breaking bad he was
the comic relief you know he was a
sleazy fast talking lawyer guy and he
was great in that role but it was better
call
saul where it was like oh you he really
gets to flex some dramatic
muscles in there flex those dramatic
muscles without losing
that which makes saul goodman so good
man i know people are like oh well i've
liked
bob odenkirk since well for me it's
breaking bad
long story short we can all agree that
dude's a great actor
and he gets to show that in here because
this movie's more of a i don't want to
say it's a slow crawl or a slow burn
but there's a lot more build up than
let's say john wick has
john wicks like a thing happens switch
gets flipped
immediate badass and that's amazing and
that's what we come for the movie
nobody's a bit different you see this
guy in his life for a bit
you can see he's just emotionally
unfulfilled he's
sad he looks depressed which i really
like if i can just have one description
this is the only review you need this
line right here nobody is
john wick meets falling down with an
emotional character that's
more akin to david dunn and unbreakable
you're right like that's
that's what it reminded me of it
reminded me of david dunn and
unbreakable because he's just not
fulfilled with this normal life he's not
doing that which he is
called to do but rather than protect
like unbreakable
is kill people but also when he's like
all right time to get kick assin
kick assin roll with me here when he's
on the bus you're like oh it's gonna go
down and he's like
quite simply i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
here we go but it's not it's not like he
just flips a switch and he's like i'm
back to action
like a splice like it never happened
like there was never any
gap like there wasn't a decade and a
long gap in between
nah he's a bit rusty he has to slough
off the rust he has to relearn it's kind
of like
this is the sequel video game you know
in the first video game you max out your
character but they make a sequel they're
like
well how do we nerf the character now in
the sequel somehow they have to have a
trinket
a sword an amulet time
that just makes the character forget
everything they learned in the previous
game so he's not completely op from the
start
that's like how this movie is he has to
remember how to be a badass he takes a
few hits he's kind of like
doomsday in the sense that any huge hit
he takes
he just gets better and stronger so i
like that i like that this movie was all
about
build-up there was a build of him being
a badass again they rolled out his
skills as the movie went on also i like
the slow reveal of his past you have
questions throughout this movie it's
like what did this guy
do how badass is he is he actually the
badass we think he is there are little
things little easter eggs little
nuggets that you get where you're like
yeah definitely this guy has a secret
and that's a big thing i need to say in
this video because people just need to
know because when they think oh the john
wick ism's like all right sweet let's
just pop it on action action action the
action is there and i
love it when it happens but it's also
spread out in the movie it's spaced out
with time to breathe in between with
these character building moments you
know it's what makes this movie
stand out this doesn't try to be a john
wick wannabe
it's its own thing i appreciate that and
it really is the bob odenkirk
show in this movie i mean connie nelson
i thought was great as his wife and
there's an intriguing story there and
they have their past it's only lightly
alluded to
but i like that i like the fact that
this movie doesn't give you all the
answers it gives you the pieces and you
just kind of piece together the past
also there are a couple of supporting
characters in this movie not big roles
but christopher lloyd
rizza both great both amazing but if i
had to peg it
i mean it's the bob odenkirk show i love
the editing in this movie too like there
were more than a few moments where i was
like that does seem like
breaking bad-esque you know like when
the action's going down
and just playing a song that you would
think would play
during a breaking bad cook segment maybe
i'm seeing the breaking bad link because
of bob odenkirk but i mean it felt like
that also a couple of moments with the
editing in general like this car crashes
like it was really cool edit the
editing's creative there's talent in the
directing
the acting is great the premise is fun
and the character moments keep you
hooked and of course let's not forget
the actions completely kick ass in
theaters right now i believe it's coming
to video on demand this weekend so this
review is
it's nice and timely however you watch
it i'll say it's worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray john wick
equalizer nobody
it's a good trinity right there
father-son holy spirit style all right
so nobody have you seen it what did you
think about it are you planning on
watching it this weekend whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you